[Music]
welcome to Kaiba riverbank behind me we
have the rebuild of the riverbank you
can see the new Coast Guard building
maritime rescue the old wharf where the
two who used to set has gone being
demolished and replaced with a rock wall
and if you can see progresses is good
it's on schedule and we're almost in the
thinnest and start planting stage behind
me here we have our new exciting
development on the south side of the
river on the main block side we have
walkway we have a technic seating areas
and we have a fishing area with
facilities for cleaning fish were those
of you lucky enough to catch fish in a
glorious river development here's into
pat on the land side kids exciting new
building comes over towards from here
the stock bank gets modified as part of
that and then the slope you're looking
at now has steps built all the way down
for sitting in the sand looking out over
the river in the river itself we have
putting 90 meters of pontoon which is
going to happen this year and you'll be
able to literally to drive up in your
first bite back there come ashore have a
latte just like the Revere contractors
as you can see the layer but they
finished the major work that we're up to
the finishing taxes for landscaping and
the planting and by next spring it will
all be looking pretty damn good
[Music]